thank you very much for being here today
my name is Christopher Shay's I'm
chairman of the Government Reform and
oversight subcommittee called human
resources and we're here to after the
full committee has adopted our report on
Gulf War illnesses this was a report
that was done during the last 19 months
about so-called Gulf War Syndrome we had
11 of substantive hearings and I'm here
with my colleagues from the committee
mr. town mr. snow burger and Mr Sanders
and this bipartisan report we just want
to make a few general comments and then
have my colleagues a comment to the dais
and just make some comments and then
respond any questions you might have
this report we've given you just the
summary of it is has 18 findings their
substantive findings and we have 18
substantive recommendations in some
cases three or four of the findings add
and support one of the recommendations
or two they don't necessarily line up a
number for number we made a
determination clearly that sadly our
soldiers were not being listened to by e
to the v a-- at VA or DoD and and so
frankly we listened and sadly we found
that when it came to diagnosis and
treatment and research that the VA and
DOD and the bureaucracies in general
have a tin ear and a very cold heart in
a very close mind we've made three
significant recommendations and I would
highlight we've made 18 significant but
three I would highlight one that we
would as an act as a matter of law the
presumption that unknown toxic exposures
call cause certain chronic symptoms the
challenge we have is that the the VA and
the DoD don't have records they don't
have records that would support our
veterans position and it's a very
convenient to position for the
bureaucracy and the government to be in
they say to that to the veteran prove
your illness and all the documents that
could prove it have either been lost or
actually destroyed by the government
secondly we would create or designate a
lead agency separate from the VA and the
DoD to provide overall direction to the
research effort only recently did the
government begin to research the effect
of low-level exposure to chemicals and I
didn't even have it in their protocols
early on as to whether a soldier might
have come in to their belief come
encounter with certain chemical exposure
and third or require a presidential
finding of need before ever again
permitting the use of experimental drugs
on on our troops I think this is the one
that that I find the most difficult I
was in fact speaking to one of your
contemporaries so someone in the news
media said that when he was in the
Persian Gulf he was ordered to take
permit the PV pill the the experimental
drug it's used for other facts but it's
not used to to in this way as it was
using the Persian Gulf to be used to
ward off exposure to chemical in to
lessen the impact of chemical it was an
experimental drug our troops were
literally under ordered to take them and
if they didn't they broke in order and
could have been court-martialed at the
very least the record should have been
kept of who what soldiers took them and
when and how often and in the future we
are going to require that that the
president sign off on any practice like
this let me at this time refer you to
mr. sander excuse me ed towns the
ranking member and I do want to say I
know that the media can get a little
tired of our congratulating each other
but this has been a bipartisan effort
and when I call mr. towns to the dais
who helped in drafting this report and
all the hearings I do so not as ranking
member but really as an equal in this
process mr. towns thank you very much
mr. chairman and
I won't congratulate you what I would
like to do though is just say that this
is a try partisan not a bipartisan so
try partisan that I'm a Democrat of
course congressman shades as a
Republican and Bernie Sanders is an
independent so I think that's a try
partisan report as a ranking Democratic
member of the subcommittee I came away
with the feeling that illnesses of the
Persian Gulf veterans should be examined
and treated research should be continued
and compensation should be provided to
those individuals whose Persian Gulf
service has rendered them disabled or
suffering from chronic illnesses I
believe that the veterans of the Persian
Gulf War deserve care compensation and
compassion as we listen to the veterans
and people who came before us over the
past 19 months we've had 11 hearings and
to listen to the kind of things that
they said and how they were sort of
ignored and sort of pushed around in
many instances we felt that we had to
get to the bottom of this and of course
we spent a lot of time and effort on
doing that so I am supporting this
report because I believe that the report
provides additional direction and go
clarification for the Department of
Veteran Affairs and the Department of
Defense I do not believe that this
report should be seen as negative it
should be viewed that something needs to
be done now instead this committees
mandated oversight Authority we're
charged with the responsibility of
making that known this is what we have
done here and this is the results of the
hard work of the committee I believe
that the agencies can now take this
report understand our perspectives and
move forward and accomplishing the goals
that we have set for them hopefully the
publication of this report will move us
from the blame game and move us into the
healing game
finally I hope this report paints a
sharp picture of the lack of
accountability which occurs during the
time of war if we learn anything from
the Gulf War hopefully we should learn
that the accountability is the
cornerstone of democracy and cannot be
abandoned even during the time of war
Thank You mr. towns at this time Vince
no burger who is the vice chairman of
the committee okay Thank You mr.
chairman I might say that I come to this
these hearings on a little different
foot than my colleagues coming in as a
freshman this year most of the hearings
had been held over the last year what I
can tell you though is that in my short
period of time serving on the committee
and in these hearings it became very
very clear to me and to my freshman
colleagues that there was a true lack of
accountability here both for the
Department of Defense and for the
Veterans Administration for more than
five years the Department of Defense
maintained that not a single American
was exposed to Iraqi chemical weapons
during or after the ground war and
whether that chemical exposure was
caused by the release of chemical agents
during the destruction of coma SIA or
whether it was they were exposed to
chemical weapons during the wartime
aggression it's totally irrelevant the
fact the matter was the Department of
Defense knew that there was exposure and
they had an obligation to inform
American troops after five years of
denial finally last year they admitted
that 400 soldiers had been exposed to
these chemical agents and then a few
months later it was up to 20,000 and a
few months after that the AP reported it
was 130 thousand american troops exposed
now we don't know exactly how many be
clearly clearly the department offense
credibility has suffered as a result of
their gradual and grudging admission
that these soldiers were actually
exposed the VA has also taken a very
relaxed approach
many of the veterans that came to VA for
treatment were treated with skepticism
and with disdain and it's clear that the
VA's treatment care of our Gulf War
veterans is shameful I think this is the
first step that we've needed to take in
trying to solve the Gulf War it's been a
very appropriate use of the oversight
process of Congress I think now the next
step is to follow through on the
recommendations and make sure that
treatment is actually given to our Gulf
War veterans for the symptoms that
they've David the suffering that they've
had during this period of time and I
think the Chairman thank the gentleman
and says pointed out the independent
member of Congress Bernie Sanders is now
going to speak to you I would like to
say that in kuala best think of
ourselves as independent yeah thank you
Chris uh I just want to say a few words
it seems to me that the bottom line of
this whole issue is the following today
there are some 70,000 men and women who
served in the Gulf War who are suffering
from one or another ailment that we
refer to as Gulf War illness including
hundreds of my own state of Vermont and
if you go to the VA and you go to the
DoD today and you say what is the cause
of the illness the tens of thousands of
Americans are suffering from they will
say we don't know and if you say to them
what kind of treatment have you
developed to improve the lives of these
people and solve their medical problems
the VA and the dld will say we don't
know and it seems to me that after six
years what the Congress must say the
department of defense in the VA thank
you very much for your efforts in
attempting to understand the causes of
Gulf War illness in attempting to
develop a treatment but you failed and
we think six years is enough and we
think we must go to another agency which
perhaps we'll do a better job in trying
to understand the problem and develop a
treatment and that's what it is about
arm it seems to me as Chris and others
have said that this is not the end of
the road this is the beginning of the
row
and we're going into new territory but I
would hope very much that the committee
and the whole Congress will work in a
non-partisan way to make sure that we
finally bring together those scientists
in the private sector and academia those
scientists are working in the government
together under the leadership of a new
agency to say let us do a better job at
understanding the cause of this problem
let's get a treatment going as soon as
possible let's marshal all of our
resources we can do no less so I
congratulate Christopher's outstanding
leadership we look forward to the
process I've had a great committee in
all three of us or all four of us who
are happy to answer any question you
might have is you feel like you guys
found the answer to the mystery of golf
or disease I think we have established
the fact that various chemical exposures
pesticides the vaccines the basically
this cesspool of chemicals is clearly a
cause of Gulf War Syndrome it's there's
not one silver bullet but we know
without a shadow of a doubt that the
records that would substantiate what
soldiers took what pills what soldiers
were in what area what chemicals were in
those areas those records don't exist
did exist but don't exist now and
therefore we have to give the
presumption to our veterans because they
can't rely on documents that have been
destroyed White House commission that
was that was set up to do the same thing
let me just say to you that we're not in
competition with the president's
Advisory Committee on Gulf War illnesses
I think all of us could speak to our
disappointment when they issued a report
basically saying that in so many words
our soldiers problems were psychological
and not physical and I'd welcome others
let me just say a word I don't think is
Chris indicated that we think that there
is a silver bullet at one magical answer
but I think what this report indicates
that the problem is far more complicated
than just calling Gulf War illness
related illness I think that is
absolutely the case and I think that's
perhaps one of the major achievements of
this report stress is in fact in my
judgment an important factor but the
issue is what is what happens when
people under stress receive protesting
my bro might receive different vaccines
when they are exposed to all kinds of
pollutants what happens in terms of the
synergistic effect and I think that's
the strength of what the report is that
I think we can all conclusively agree
that stress alone is not the cause of
golf Williams from here do you intend or
hope that President Clinton takes the
initiative to shift this out of VA and
DOD or will you will I mean if obviously
I'll have to come through Congress or
will you take that initiative whose I
think I like that next collectively we
will be going to our own leadership
Republican Democrat we will be going to
the White House with our report this is
a report that we want to have looked at
seriously because we think we have some
very constructive findings and
recommendations and ultimately we're
talking about research as it relates to
the VA and DOD we want it under the
control of someone other than the DoD
and VA but they obviously are going to
continue to do their research and
they're obviously going to be helping
and working to heal our soldiers our
soldiers are still going to go to the VA
but in terms of just the recalcitrance
of the of the bureaucracy one on finding
nine and this is just a one of our
findings we say acute diagnosis of
veterans illnesses remains difficult due
to inadequate or missing personnel
medical records missing toxic detection
logs and unreleased classified documents
I've been in possession to these
documents almost since they were
established in 1994 I have gone to
senators I have gone to chairman of
committees to have them look at these
documents and release them one is
defense hotline allegations regarding
fielding of chemical protective masks
another is called Quick Reaction report
reliability the m 17
an m14 chemical protective mask I can
basically say to you that these call
into question the effectiveness of the
mass that our soldiers took this is just
one example of something our veterans
need to be able to see if they use these
mess they still have a right to know how
effective they were and I can't release
this report I have pleaded with mr.
Oscar to to see that these are released
he said he would see that it was done
and he didn't and this is just one
example of many that our veterans have a
right of information they have a right
to know the records were destroyed how
are the works destroy others want to
speak that good um records we had
testimony that some records were just
simply destroyed not considered valuable
we have three quarters of the connect
chemical biological and nuclear
documents not they can't find
three-quarters of them the irony is that
the DoD can find documents that prove
their case or not prove it but
substantiate but can't find documents
that would prove the arguments of the
veterans and yet we had we had testimony
from people in the Fox equipment now
what what happened was that it's very
clear that none of the detection systems
went off before the war they went off
thousands hundreds and hundreds during
the war these were not calibrated
finally as DoD has told us and but the
argument was why during the war and not
before the war if they were not if they
weren't reliable but then in some cases
we had testimony from two individuals in
Fox equipment Fox equipment is equipment
you you're in you don't get out of that
makes very fine readings and we had
testimony from from trained personnel
that they detected a biological excuse
me chemical weapons the use of not
weapons but the exposure of chemicals
and the army just said well they're
wrong but they can't find the
information they've lost the documents
that these soldiers swear that they had
had had seen and helped
find and put into the system and their
documents aren't now available well that
to me as an outrage but is frankly very
typical of those I can't say its
intention though I can't say it's
intentional all I can say is it is it is
a gigantic curiosity to some of us in
the committee why some documents can be
fine that are helpful to the DoD's
position which basically is that our
troops weren't exposed to chemicals not
to give credit to one program but 60
minutes had mr Joyce Sean where he said
and I loved his wording there was no
offensive use of kemple chemicals we
have no knowledge of offensive use how
wonderful a statement kemah SIA was
defensive we destroyed camassia now the
CIA had documentation early on before
the war in 89 the chemicals were there
they knew after the war that we had
destroyed this depot and the only way
that the dld just so you know why we
sometimes become a little suspicious we
had testimony from brian martin on a
Tuesday ryan martin a staff sergeant he
had a film of chemistry because he was
there when they blew it up and he had a
film of the plumes he had a film of some
of the rockets and shells that
documented that chemicals were there
when DoD learned that we had had this
testimony at 12 on a friday they
announced at four o'clock on on friday
they would have a press conference to
acknowledge that only 400 that not only
but 400 of our soldiers were exposed to
chemicals well we then subsequently
found that the plumes didn't go up in
the air and fall down they went 12 15
and 20 miles out and that doesn't even
address the the immense number of
biological and chemical plants that we
bombed from the air and in all the
studies we were told the plumes would go
away from the troops not towards and
that's getting to this issue now of how
many have been exposed because the
blooms went towards our troops
News 8 is this has been intentional acts
in terms of the information are coming
out and how much of it you think is just
simply that the people of bureaucracy is
probably nobody in the world open but
let me just say two things pick up the
point that Chris was making there is no
question and I think any of our minds
that the DoD and the CIA have been
absolutely horrendous in terms of of
being forthcoming for whatever reason
about the problems it is not acceptable
that in the beginning they virtually
denied there was a problem you remember
that all there is no problem oh then I
guess there is a problem but the problem
is stress-related certainly no chemicals
played a role Oh none none what so well
maybe maybe a few hundred troops might
have been exposed well maybe was twenty
thousand well I guess we think it's a
hundred thousand an on and it was like
pulling teeth that is half the problem
and chris is absolutely right the other
half of the problem is be that as it may
we need to understand the cause of gulf
war illness if tomorrow the DoD said
came forward and did a fantastic job in
detailing every single aspect of what
occurred that would be great but you
know what that still might not give us
the cause of the illness or an effective
treatment so we've got to move forward
in two separate ways and as Chris said
we've got to continue to pull out
information we've got to hold those
people accountable who have not given us
the information but secondly let us not
take our eyes off the prize and the
prize is understanding the illness and
developing a treatment so that we can
restore some of those lives that have
been so terribly wronged me exactly what
the new agency will be expected to do
that is going to be the basis for our
continued hearing so you know we didn't
quite know when to end the first phase
and do a report and just continue on
because we kept finding more more things
to report so we just arbitrarily said
this is the point we're going to file
our report and it is substantive and now
we're going to the next stage and and
that next stage will require us to
recommend to come
Congress what agency should direct the
research I think Mr Sanders has one
recommendation that we would consider
and might want to talk about it and then
we'll we could talk to others okay i
think the agency that we want is going
to be an agency that has the courage to
take a hard look at the recommendations
in this report and say yeah we think
that it is very likely that chemicals
and produced igg my bromide have played
a role in Gulf War illness in the labor
HHS legislation with Chris's help and
other people's help we managed to get
some language into the report which will
direct over a seven-year period seven
million dollars into the National
Institute of Environmental Health
Sciences okay and we think that they
have indicated and have told us that
they are interested in pursuing that
issue so I think that's an area to maybe
begin looking at but it's chris
indicated we're gonna have to take a
hard look but they are one agency that i
think is a possibility but me within NIH
there is an institute called the
National Institute of Environmental
Health Sciences are led by dr. ken olden
you know quickly do you think you can
put together the presumptive legislation
and how would you assess its chances and
house and Sonny just speakin you mind
speaking but ms no I'm just gonna sort
of add you know I think that we want to
be very careful as to how we move and
when we move we would need to get some
additional information in before we
could determine in terms of what really
needs to happen but we know for a fact
that what is going on now needs to be
fixed and that's what we will try and do
but the point is that we will not do it
you know very quickly because we want to
have some hearings and get additional
information from people experts out
there is what really should happen you
know we've discovered some things here
which I think reminds me what happens in
the Board of Education you know where
you have a school where you have all
kinds of problems and the principal will
say there's no problems in our school
because if he admits to the fact that it
points out that I'm not a good principle
I'm not a good leader so I think we see
some of this coming out of here so we
need to make certain that what we do in
terms of fixing this is that we don't
make some of the mistakes that we've
made in the past so I would be one that
would say let us cautiously move we know
it has broken
needs to be fixed and we should fix it
and make their account of recommendation
for that happen with the input coming
from experts you know I'd also say that
you know say arbitrarily decided we
thought we were at a good point if this
report suggested who should take it over
that would be the focus of everybody's
attention and they would not focus on
the first 18 findings in the first 18
recommendation so you know that's
another factor but we're going to look
at that it relates to another point
though the whole issue of environmental
sciences and who is qualified one of the
most troubling things for me was in the
course of asking the VA who has
background in chemical exposure
environmental sciences how many doctors
do you have because they have thousands
and they could only name one and then
they got back to us because we wanted to
and and there were four toxicologists in
the entire VA now environmental sciences
is an area that's fascinating to get
into and you would think the VA and the
DoD would want to have tremendous
expertise in this whole issue of
low-level exposure as a former member of
the state legislature I voted on OSHA
laws I voted on on laws that said people
in the workplace shouldn't be exposed to
low level chem a chemical exposure
because it leads ultimately to chronic
illness which flew right in the face of
what mr. Joseph said to us from the
Pentagon he said low-level exposure
doesn't lead to acute illness and we had
a gigantic disagreement there and they
backed off that and they then said that
will no longer be our presumption that
was one of the values of our hearing but
a point i want to make to you is that
it's very clear to me that the
Department of Defense carries very
little about environmental science and
and and what happens to our soldiers in
the battlefield and before lindane was
used to to to clean the Iraqi soldiers
we had a soldier who died in Connecticut
who spent hours and hours every day in
an enclosed tent without any ventilation
spraying troops Iraqi troops with Lyndon
now he died of pancreas cancer and
people say well there's no relationship
between the two but we
no that lindane can't be used that way
by a worker in in American society
because it's dangerous and just one
other area of area that we are going to
focus in on the depleted uranium our
soldiers were not told that when they
went into an Iraqi tank that was was
penetrated by a depleted uranium shell
this is a long spear that is harder than
any other substance it goes in and
penetrates into a tank and then it
becomes a particle form and that becomes
highly dangerous and our soldiers were
not told about that now Iraqis would
like to say candidly the whole problem
is depleted uranium but there are a lot
of issues that we have got to look at
and that's and that's one of the men
that will continue ever but you had a
question the time frame are you on and
what kind of chances are recommendations
and the legislation to establish a
presumption um we I will be working and
having the legislation ready to go to
start the beginning of the new calendar
year legislative agenda and we'll be
going to our speaker and we'll be going
to the minority leader to ask them to
move forward on this rock and ornamented
the relevant committees of course the
Rockefeller last week introduced some
legislation that would take at least a
few years to establish a presumption
working through the Department of
Veterans Affairs and could take several
years to establish presumption are you
willing to accept that kind of a time
trying no I I'd like him to look at this
report he's done excellent work and this
is the team effort but I i think that
when he you know fully on when he sees
what we saw the fact of the lost records
destroyed records the recognition that
soldiers can't prove their illnesses
because the records don't exist that we
have a moral obligation to move much
more quickly than than a few years maybe
some others would just speak on that
issue argue just you want to know what I
agree with the comment that was that was
made I think that you know here again
that this report and I've been in the
Congress 16 years and this report is
very thorough a lot of time and effort
was put into it and I think
that once people get it and they read it
they see it I think that the reaction is
going to be different even with the
members of Congress so I think that once
they see it on the other side then I
think that they will understand the
importance of really trying to move as
fast as we possibly can recognizing that
we will have to have input coming you
know along the way but i think this
report can make a difference in terms of
a lot of attitudes a treatment in the
meantime we've seen every time they
start up one of these presidential
Commission's or pentagon you know does
the roster thing that's two years later
because this one the Pentagon
establishes the new roster unit learning
the Presidential Commission you all are
now saying take the research away from
them put it somewhere else treatment in
the meantime letting these two agencies
that you don't trust to do the research
do the main treatment for these folks
what do we do in the meantime let me
make two points and pick up a point that
Chris made a few moments ago which may
well be at close to the root of the poke
of the problem it may well be that Gulf
War the problem that the VA and the DoD
has had is that Gulf War illness is
related to a new kind of problem that
they have not dealt with before in other
words if somebody got shot up or hit by
shrapnel probably the dld in the VA may
have the best processes in the entire
world to treat those problems that's
what they have been trained to do but as
Chris indicated what happens when you've
been given puristic mind bromide exposed
to various types of pesticides burning
oil wells and given certain vaccines
what is their background in dealing with
that type of problem very very little so
it seems to me that we want to go to
those people who have the expertise in
that area now in terms of treatment the
good news and there is some good news is
that there is research being done all
over the country by serious scientists
who have been talking about the
synergistic impact the various chemicals
might have in creating Gulf Woolf's and
it seems to me that we have got to have
the courage to reach out and bring those
people into the tent and not say well
gee I'm not quite so familiar with out
what they're up doctors even within the
V
a who have been developing certain types
of treatments called avoidance therapy
based on their belief the chemicals
played a role they were kind of pushed
out of the VA it's not acceptable don't
don't talk about that we don't believe
in that it seems to me that we as a
Congress representing the American
people have the moral obligation to
bring in anybody and everybody who is
doing serious research and who is doing
treatment protocols is everybody going
to be right out there I don't think so
but I think we've got to bring them in
we've got to welcome them in and we've
got to give them their day in the
process up to this point the VA in the
DoD frankly have not done that so I
guess the main point that I'm making is
let's open the door people are hurting
we know that there are doctors out there
who are developing various types of
treatments are they effective or not
let's bring them in and find out let's
just not push them aside here let me
just conclude then by saying that the
bottom line for this committee is that
we want our troops properly diagnosed we
want them effectively treated and we
want them fairly compensated and we want
the research to be effective and we want
it to begin in more intensity and we
want it better coordinated and we
clearly do want it the direction of the
research the research will still be done
in part by the VA and DOD but the
direction of the research handled by an
agency other than those two that I
mentioned thanks very much for coming
don't we
Oh